[Music]
jack 75
let's go e4
and uh again we see a philidor which
we've seen a lot and we know that the
move is d4 opening up the center
at this point i will not spend a long
time on the opening you guys know the
drill we're just developing pieces
naturally
and we do know those of you who are
attentive to previous streams
castling here is inaccurate does
somebody know why and can somebody tell
me how we avoid
this particular type of trap
why is castling a very natural move not
that good
because of knight takes e4 knight takes
c4 and then d5
exactly so how do we avoid that where do
we tuck one of our pieces away so that
this isn't a thing
what's up tommy h3 doesn't actually do
anything against
the idea of knight takes c4 we go bishop
to b3 we talk the bishop away this is a
very typical move in many types of
positions
and now we can very safely castle now it
is true that he can okay he doesn't do
it
he puts his knight on e5 that is a bit
of a weird move
because what can we do with this knight
and uh in a manner conducive to our
general kingside ideas
which is to start the attack let's go f4
chase the night away
the knight can go to many different
places he can go back to d7 which is
what he does
and now we have to decide how we are
going to continue the attack
there's many ways of doing it there's
many good moves here i think
but one idea that comes to my mind is to
prepare perhaps the pawn break e5 trying
to open up the center
we can't do that immediately and i want
you guys to be very patient here because
if we play e5 immediately we will lose
the pawn
i also don't want to go rookie one and
the reason i don't want to go rookie one
is because when we go e5 if and when
and he takes and we take i want this
rook to be on f1 because it will be
uniquely poised
to exploit the opening of the f-file so
this is forward thinking we want to keep
the rook here in anticipation
of the if the file getting opened
so this is a pretty big balls task we
can go queen e2 but we know from our
principle
that we shouldn't assign a task to a
piece of higher value
when we can assign it to a piece of
lower value and that piece of lower
value is the knight this is a retreating
move
but it's a very strong retreating move
because we are preparing something very
aggressive but let's not go e5
immediately
let's not go e5 yet if we go e5
immediately we allow the queen trade
so first we're going to get the queen to
e1 this kills two birds with one stone
first of all prepare c5
second of all we prepared to bring our
queen onto a very strong
attacking post and now we can go e5 adam
thank you for the prime appreciate it
you can see how methodically we're
playing here
okay what do we do how do we proceed
in this position
and actually i'm asking you guys a
pretty simple question pretty
trick question because you might be
looking for something extraordinary but
i always remind people never to forget
about your development we have not
completed our development
we have an entire side of the board that
is not developed thank you queen g3
blunders the queen
we just develop our pieces now yes we
give up our bishop that's painful
because the bishop
is skewering the diagonal but that is
okay no mission way may thank you for
the prime
why is that okay because his pieces are
all over the board his knight is in the
corner
and now he's gonna get blown out of the
gym here he doesn't even
decide to take my bishop
what do we do now
how do we continue tightening the screw
as we go knight t5 very good you know
work
centralizing the knight we are not
attacking the pawn but we are
centralizing the knight the knight is
controlling many squares
we could have also gone h3 to get rid of
this very annoying pin
i should have gone h that was that was a
better move knight d5 was a little bit
impulsive but that's okay
because black is so passive here we can
afford to even go back to c3
if we want to if we wanted which is what
we're going to do and i want to show
people that it's okay
to admit your mistakes in chess and i
guess in life too although
we don't like to do that very much
anymore
okay now let's go h3 to get rid of this
pin
i told you guys a principal principle
yesterday that helps you assess whether
pins are dangerous does somebody
remember what this principle is
okay what do we do now
sorry i'm getting
i found peter gionatos is distracting me
okay um what do we do now
how do we continue
well what do we need to look for here
what we need to look at is the knight on
h5
we need to make the judgment that our
pieces are
so well placed that we can now proceed
to basically the kick-ass phase
and the knight on h5 is in the corner
and it is trapped we just win the night
uh-huh are you
are you here
how do we know if the pin is dangerous
sorry so if a pinned piece is defended
by a pawn
then the pin is then the pin tends to be
a little bit less dangerous if the
pinned piece is not defended by a pawn
then normally the pin should be
considered quite dangerous that's not a
hard fast rule
but it's a good shorthand for assessing
whether you need to deal with a pin
immediately
because the bishop is pinning the knight
but okay f5
is well that's a terrible move because
he blunders another knight now a lot of
people here would make the knee-jerk
response and take the knight on h5 but
let's spend a second looking for a
better move
if you notice the move f5 has opened up
the diagonal for the bishop
the knight on e6 is protected only by
the queen and the queen is overloaded
why is it overloaded what can we do in
order to get this queen out of e8
such that it will not no longer defend
the knight on e6
come on guys give me the move rook takes
the a bingo
taking one knight and then taking the
other in succession we're going to be up
two pieces
and the game is going to be over simple
and strong
simple and strong
and keep cameras on 14 for the prime
let's keep the hype going i'm loving it
okay so we're up two pieces
negative 1456 he gives us more stuff but
we got to be a little bit careful here
i think we can just take this guy i mean
he's probably intending queen d4 check
thinking that he forks us
okay well that's just an empty check we
can move our king up
and uh thank you deck jumper
now how do we win a position like this
we win it by by centralizing our pieces
and essentially going after his king we
don't need to trade anything
one way that i immediately am thinking
about of going after his king is to
build a battery
against the h7 square building a battery
is is sort of one of the key attacking
principles in any position
but here in particular because he
doesn't have a light squared bishop this
battery is going to be essentially
unstoppable he's actually helping us
build it
uh by sending the bishop over to d3 i
would have gone there anyway
and our next move is going to be queen
e4 with humongous threats against h7
1994 is possible as well these positions
are so winning
that we can basically do anything we
want and win it
okay he's moving my pieces yep exactly
queen h queen e4
threatening checkmate he's got to play
g6 in order to prevent it which is
incredibly exposing
then we're going to move our knight and
follow follow that with with uh hg6
he can take our pawn but then again he
exposes the attack on the
h7 square thank you barry mccockinner
for gifting to jay hubes
loving the support right now
what's typically more powerful rooker
bishop well the queen bishop battery is
my personal favorite as we get the rook
to an open file newly created
okay rook g8 we're gonna take
and now we're gonna go we're gonna go
knight g3 bringing the knight
into the attack
he's threatening h4 let's win a third
piece with a fork
there's so many ways of winning this
position that i'm not even really
commenting
on the way that i choose now we're gonna
get i don't even care about the night
we're up so many pieces that
whatever i'm just gonna get the queen of
six i'm gonna
whatever just bishop h6 here forcing the
queen trade
which actually also helps me create a
pass pawn which i will promote
with checkmate because this game is
boxed in
all right good game
um very quickly and i'm gonna do one or
two then maybe switch back to blitz
essentially he should have taken the
bishop i mean
this bishop actually won us the game he
should have taken the bishop
but here we play a takes b3 get the rook
to d1
and uh eventually we're going to chase
this bishop away from g4 that's why they
say knights on the rim are grim
now sometimes nights on the rim are good
if they're accomplishing something
specific
but here one good way to think about
knights on the rim is whether they have
an evacuation route going forward and
here the knight from h5 does not have an
evacuation round it is trapped
it is very dangerous to have a piece
like this which has no
which a is is on the side of the board
where it can be attacked and b
has no evacuation path why not queen h4
instead i
assume of g4
so queen h4 would have been possible as
well yeah this would have i was a little
bit concerned
that he would take the knight on c3
though and now we run into a little bit
of trouble
because our rook on d1 loses its
defender
we have to play rook take state and now
he takes with the queen now remember
he is currently up a piece because he's
captured our knight we cannot take two
pieces at the same time and our queen is
hanging
we've got too many things to deal with
here we have to take one of the pieces
either take the queen and then take the
bishop and then he can get an evacuation
route for his night
or we take the knight but we are no
longer up a piece he moves his bishop
away and he's fine
so the reason i rejected queen h4 is
because i was a little bit worried
that the rook on d1 would be poorly
protected
uh seeing that the bishop can capture
the knight i didn't calculate this but
it was an intuitive judgment film
okay um
so instead of playing f5 he should have
just given up one piece but he decided
to give up two i mean that's often
what happens uh when people panic
and uh that basically was the whole game
i mean i didn't really do anything
specific
i think the important moment was here i
mean i'm not claiming that white is even
better here but i'm trying to illustrate
a concept
which is that when you come up with an
idea you want to find the best way to
execute that idea and the higher rated
you get
the more complex the executions become
here
a lot of people want to go rookie one
but to remind everybody the rook
on f1 is uniquely poised to exploit that
f-file once it opens so not only do you
want to position pieces on good squares
and in a sense in a sense using our
terminology the rook has a lot of
potential energy
it has very very low kinetic energy
because it's staring at a pawn
it's on its almost on its initial square
but
it has tremendous potential if the
f-file opens and that's what makes it
hard to appreciate
this rook's this rick's power
okay any questions before i go on
if queenie ii well queen e2 another
drawback is that
in such a situation the knight on d4
loses its protector so
the reason i wanted to keep the queen on
d1 for the time being is that when i
play e5 i anticipated the d-file opening
and when the d-file opens the knight on
d4 might be caught on the crossfire
and it would be nice if the queen
remained there to defend the knight
let's continue
okay lexman 18 let's go e4
and let's play either the italian or the
roy lopez
okay he goes d5 the elephant gambit
we've faced it many times on sound
but not as bad as people make it out to
be we will take on d5
now the normal continuation here is e4
yep so this guy actually knows what he's
doing
and if i if my memory serves me correct
then we actually do not move the knight
here can somebody tell me
what possible move we have that doesn't
involve moving the knight
how do we what is the alternative way
yup queen e2 and this pawn
is going to be picked off because he
doesn't have any pieces out to defend
the spawn what do we do
how do we get to this pawn on e4 now
that it's defended by
f5 we don't have much time to waste we
need to
operate quickly so we go d3
we go d3 now we continue to attack this
pawn
we can take once but there's no need to
do that just yet
so what should we do and this is
actually a very interesting moment
so we could go knight g5 but i would
prefer to develop
while we attack the pawn so let's go
knight to c3
and now let's take the pawn on e4 once
let's see what he
recaptures with he plays bishop takes c3
to take away this makes a lot of sense
to take away the attacker of the e4 pawn
but here's the thing remember that we're
upon up from a previous marriage we are
upon up still
and even if we don't get to this pawn
that's fine
as long as we can protect the pawn on d5
can we protect the pawn on d5 can we
protect the pawn on d5
yeah so c4 is possible but i want to
look for something better
because here is my fear with the move c4
if we play c4
and he castles we are uncastled
and not only are we on castle but the
queen on e2 is blocking our bishop from
developing
so i would anticipate some trouble
tactically speaking
if he gets this big lead in development
now this refocuses our priorities and
our priority becomes not
saving the pawn but actually stopping
him from castling
if we can stop him from castling we
equalize the playing field
not only that we have two bishops that
can be very useful in an open board
can we stop him from castling yes we can
bishop a3
the move queen b5 is very tempting but
as i've reminded people
always remember that checks can be
blocked when you give a check you
shouldn't assume that the king has to
move
move bishop a3 prevents him from
castling by taking under control
the f8 square now the queen has come out
to d5 which
immediately signals to us that we can
deploy some of our pieces with tempo
while attacking the queen now which
piece in particular do i have my eye on
and how do we deploy it indeed rook d1
and we can see that his king is in big
trouble it might not seem that way right
now but it is
he attacks our bishop he attacks our
pawn can we defend both at the same time
yes we can bishop b4 obviously we give
up a2 but as people should be realizing
by now
our priority isn't pawns our priority is
to go for checkmate
and uh if that requires okay he doesn't
take the pawn
now he actually is also playing quite
quite well but
i think we can we can make this happen
now we want to get the c4 pawn
if we get the c4 pawn then that that
constitutes an immediate avenue toward
his king
how do we go after this e4 pawn is the
key question we have to ask ourselves
and the answer presents itself simply
the move is knight g5
attacking on e4 what we've done is we're
buying our self-time
because he finally goes c5 finally
interfering with the bishop he can
castle
but it's a little bit too late because
what move can we now play
despite the fact we ask ourselves the
sam shanklin question
the knee-jerk response for people is to
move the bishop away
but we ask ourselves what happens if we
do it anyway what happens if we take on
e4 anyway
and what we realize is that we create
discovered attack potential against the
king which means that if he takes our
bishop
we can at the very least recapture his
knight with a double check
and send his king out he decides to
castle
but now we can do what this knight on e4
combines with the bishop on b4
we take on c5 we win the exchange and
he's going to be down a whole lot of
material provided that we can complete
our development which shouldn't be that
difficult
now that we've basically destroyed his
remaining forces
yes i will show everything after the
game now this is a
very instructive moment we are still
behind the development so
it would be a good idea to trade queens
if the the occasion permits
but we shouldn't limit ourselves to that
thinking our bishop
is hanging in our pawn on c3 is saying
can we defend both at the same time
rook d8 would blunder the pawn on c3
with rather devastating consequences
so don't look only at your ideas look
also your opponent's ideas the threat is
not only king takes f8 it is also queen
takes c3
we need to combine both and we do that
by playing bishop to b4 sliding the
bishop back again do not be afraid of
retreating moves
the other benefit of this move is that
rook t8 is going to come with check
driving his king out that's a pretty big
deal we also have the idea of queen c 4
chuck forcing the queen trait so
depending on what he does we either go
after his king
or we go after the queen trade he can't
prevent both at the same time at least i
don't see a way to do that
particularly okay so which one should we
go for now
maybe even both
which one does your intuition calls for
definitely rook d8 i mean this looks
like it's very close to checkmate
check on f8 driving his king out even
further
and in such a situation a lot of people
struggle finding follow-ups
and they forget that pawns are
full-fledged attackers
when you can't find a way to get to a
king like this you need to involve your
pawns
pawns can be that deciding factor which
turned the attack from just
strong to decisive which fun can we
involve here
let's go g4 with tempo attacking the
bishop not only is this a good move from
an attacking perspective but if you
notice the bishop on f1 we can actually
fianchetto it
just for a little bit of safety for a
little life insurance we can always
castle short
if things go terribly wrong and we need
to escape so it's a good idea to play in
this way where you defend and attack
kind of at the same time
because then you insure yourself against
disasters if a disaster happens at least
we know that we will always be able to
castle in fact we can just castle
so that we don't even have to worry
about it i don't want the headache
of that king being out in the open okay
he gives up another rook
he was of course pinned and that's the
reason why we could afford to spend all
this time
okay that doesn't do anything so let's
deploy our last remaining piece which is
not doing anything
and let's combine attacking the king
with
just taking up all of the free pawns and
pieces that present themselves here
there's no science to winning a position
like this
tommy shelby oh look at this man go five
gifted subs from
from the unlikeliest source tommy thank
you thank you for the five gifted
that 1 30 hype we're feeling it
yeah i think he is easy
well we don't have to worry about a
measly pawn we can drop our queen all
the way to e8 with checkmate
um so this is completely winning
yeah it's over we are up too many pieces
he thinks he's thinking but i mean
there's no way he can salvage this
or survive for more than a couple moves
yeah i'm in eastern time zone
all right
i blundered eight i did blunder eight
actually
that's really funny i forgot that he was
well the hilarious thing is i didn't
even see that the rook was hanging but
the funny thing is
if he takes my rook we take his knight
we force
liquidation into a position where we're
up a rook so that's actually a good
thing
that's fine um i actually forgot that
he's attacking my rope to be honest i
didn't understand what the purpose of d5
was i made the same mistake i
tell everybody not to make i didn't ask
myself what the threat was
because i let my guard down we're up so
many pieces that i kind of let my guard
down but
as it turns out we're so overwhelmingly
better that even a blunder turns out to
be a decent move
thank you natsukis appreciate it
okay
yeah i'm surprised he hasn't taken it
yet i mean maybe he he senses something
this move does nothing yeah i i
dismissed it too early and that's a
common cause of blunders you just
dismiss the move of your opponent
because it looks stupid and he resigns
so he recognizes the the uh futility of
further resistance and he resides
so by the way if he takes my rook i take
his i can even take with my queen
which is a funny thing because bishop
takes bishop take forks
forex is queen and king he's got to take
and we're up a look
okay um so that was a relatively
straightforward game there were a couple
of interesting moments the first was the
smoke queen e2
which pins his pawn to his king and
basically he bites off a little bit more
than he can chew
and here this this was the critical
moment in the whole game because
most people would play c4 uh and that's
a completely understandable move you are
defending
your extra pawn but the issue is that he
castles and as i explained not only does
he
is he castled and we aren't but the
second bad thing is that this queen on
e2
uh actually obstructs the development of
our bishop so he starts developing a
very big initiative white is probably
still better but i didn't want to allow
a situation like this and so we played
bishop a3
giving up the pawn back which allows us
to open the d file and get it get a huge
attack against his king
we have simply more pieces in the game
than he does and he's not able to to
hold everything together
so takes if he takes the bishop we we
take with the discovered check and that
is devastating
and the rest is uh it's very simple
bishop c5 bishop f8
bringing the bishop back when you have
this position is also important
tommy [ __ ] shelby is challenging me
interesting
i gotta play him all right i gotta play
tommy
i can't pass up this opportunity we've
never played before then i'll continue
the game
he is a legend okay so he's playing the
petrov where we take on e5
and he plays the stafford gambit if only
i had made a video
refuting the stafford gambit well this
is my time
for testing d3 is the move now bishop c5
in the stafford
is typical okay
bishop c5 in the stafford is is typical
and i actually have to remember
my own refutation if i remember
correctly and just give me a second to
recall this
i think the move i recommended is bishop
b2 first
covering the g4 square and now we play a
very important move c3
the this is the move that refutes the
stafford because it prepares the move d4
shutting the bishop out taking it out of
commission and ending all tricks
associated with the f2 square
that is the key black is simply a pawn
down and he is essentially losing
uh there is nothing to it i made a 25
minute video on youtube
where i analyzed this in great depth if
you are interested you are welcome to
watch now
not to overstate the case here we still
need to win the game we are up a pawn
but we still need to bring all our
pieces out and we need to convert this
which will not be trivial but we've done
the job of
of ending the immediate tricks so let's
now develop our pieces
the knight will come out to d2 a nice
little square notice that our nice
little pawn chain in the center is well
protected he's probably going to castle
long which is fine
and if he castles along we need to start
thinking about ways that we can
attack his king on the queen side what
can we do here to start the attack on
his king
well one thing we can do first of all he
wants to play c5 and undermine our
center
which is kind of annoying can we do both
things at once we go b4
first of all we prepare the pawn storm
on the queen side second of all
we stop him from playing c5 which is
very important
the other thing we do is we prepare
potentially the maneuver of the knight
to c5
uh where it will be sitting on an
outpost if he takes it and we open up
the b
file and we can use that b file to
deliver checkmate potentially
tommy is great um okay so let's see what
he does
let's see what he does
yeah this is what drives people crazy
now he sacks the wow that is a very
strong move actually
well that's a very interesting i'm not
sure it's that strong but it's
interesting because he takes on d4 we'll
have to
we have to deal with a couple threats
here and what threats do we have to deal
with specifically he's not attacking the
rook that's defended he's only attacking
the bishop
but we need to be very careful about
where we put this bishop because if we
drop it to e2
we give the e4 pawn up and then he
develops huge pressure in the center
so where should we put the bishop in
order to keep everything
relatively nicely protected we should
put it on
c2 you should put it on c2
and our goal here is to castle if we can
manage to castle
then any shenanigans associated with
white's king and being in the centers
are going to be immediately ended
that is going to be our immediate
priority to castle
now it's a little uncomfortable to be in
this position with white but
let's remember that we're up a piece and
he has no real threats uh
it's always okay so he makes a very
strong bishops before stopping us from
castling
but the reality is black doesn't have
enough pieces in the game
to truly inflict any damage on our
position let's bring the bishop back to
e3
get this queen out of our grill it can
actually come to c3
but then we're gonna pick this queen off
with another piece an unexpected hero is
going to
make its way out of the gate what am i
talking about what is white's move here
to try to get this queen out of the
picture
yeah it's coming at me but it's fine
yeah rook c1 let's bring the rook in
let's try to get this queen out of here
no he's playing very very well tommy's
good
tommy is very good
let's get this queen out of here he
plays a brilliant move again
but let's get that queen out of here
now we finally managed to get the queen
out of our
face but we still have the problem now
of of not being able to castle and the
culprit is this bishop on
on c4 let's try to win this bishop can
we win this bishop
charlotte chesson are still here not
rook b1
look at the skewer kinetic energy not
rook b1 rook b1 queen a6
come on guys fine find the move bishop
a4 yeah queen is overloaded we can take
the rook and we win the game
oh but he does have an idea
and then i'll switch back to blitz
okay he takes on d2 we just don't want
to take with the queen because then the
bishop on a4 is lost let's stick with
the bishop
and then maybe drop the bishop bishop
back to b3
okay we're gonna see where he goes let's
go bishop b3 trading the bishop
then that queen's going to be stopping
us from castling it's a lifelong battle
but but getting the queen out of a6 is
going to be very easy we can just
interpose it with our own queen
which will come to c4 and finally not
only will be up a rook
but we are finally ready to castle in
fact this forces the queen trade
because we are in effect forking his
queen and the knight on e4 so he's got
to take
takes this he loses the knight and
finally we are going to be able to
castle and we're going to win
so again i don't care about this this
spot on e4 that's that's not
important uh what is important is that
we got rid of his bishop now we got rid
of his queen
and we are ready to castle on fourth
queen trade good game tommy
okay one second please
okay yeah that was the stafford uh as
you can see it
even with the reputation it's uh there's
there are some latent
ideas there but by and large um
by and large if you're very careful you
should be able to
to to to to ward up the threads e5 in
what position
e5 in which position
c3 is well c3 is the refutation yeah
i'm not one of several
after queen b5
well the movie 5 he can actually take on
e5 for example
and if knight takes c4 he he we lose the
queen with check
so and also remember that oh i guess he
wanted to go bishop f5 check and then
win the bishop but
maybe he can even drop it to d7 and then
you don't have a discovery with a bishop
so
but the main reason i wouldn't play e5
is because if queen takes c5
knight takes c4 after bishop c4 is
possible
but this creates some discomfort because
if you move your queen you allow a fork
if you move it to c1 then this gets very
very dangerous you take
he takes on e4 he gets his rook to e8
and it's very very uh very very nasty so
so i think i actually played it
accurately we have to be careful in such
positions
but that was basically the lay of the
land
[Music]
you